[Music]
in wrong event new said by tip and case
five ever because it's 2005 ever more
than four that's a long time alright a
woman took her dog to a furry convention
thinking it was an event for pets or so
am free
it's your pubic region so furs are
people that like to dress up in full-on
costume like animal costume [ __ ] each
other living daylight and yeah it turns
the Mohnish thing so that's what furries
are so how does she even find his
convention did it was it like the furry
convention she goes oh I'm gonna bring
my puppy it's close to the convention
hmm you didn't think it was odd that
there was a buff man with a big [ __ ]
furry like werewolf outfit on Abbi it
could have been like a mascot like Elmo
just trying to [ __ ] this [ __ ] out you
should hey you know he's a furry the
monster yeah he is a referee I don't
know from what I know about phrases like
animals specific I don't know so anyways
so this woman her name is Cheryl she's
from Michigan and so Cheryl she is a
retired state parole even better and a
part-time dog trainer so this events
this convention called furry con hit her
up asking if she'd be down to do a
presentation for their there for the
nonprofit at this event
she's like well I don't really quite
understand what this convention is for
but sure I'm down she said that she
usually does some research the night
before she goes to these events but
their website was pretty obscure and
that
had had links and information on how to
register but there were no pictures so
she just assumed it was just like a
regular business convention so she was
like alright cool I'll take link and not
gonna do a presentation there so mini
saw Cookie Monster doggy style sucking
Gonzo's there sucking some dick and [ __ ]
gonzo no Bernie just [ __ ] it add BDSM
and chains all the non animals keep
telling with something I know women are
free yeah but that's the only ones that
would kind of a little Fergus is the
only one oh yeah Big Bird big bird and
[ __ ] stuff love is [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of each other
ha ha ha Oh that'd be great bar big
we're just [ __ ] stroking his [ __ ]
trunk ok so the reason why this even got
out was because son tweeted this out
saying my mom thought freak on was a pet
event and volunteered with our therapy
dog oh my god [ __ ] dope outfits this
isn't sexual fetish stuff then I was
thinking of furry comics where they like
it's like hentai but they're furries I
don't know but they do engage in sexual
yeah so I wanted to get horny watching
dogs hump big probably you smiling all
the time yes because she was saying like
he was so excited because he had never
seen humans like with tails and like
things like that so he kept going up to
them sniffing their plastic people
sure was like I can't fall we had boners
she she was like I kept apologizing but
they were really nice about it they
didn't mind of course because they do it
again doing this snip my [ __ ] what a
cute dog I want a dog like that dude
just [ __ ] animal costume must be so
sweaty and a hot and disgusting
are you sure they all [ __ ] that's the
woods being reported and that's what I
what's up that's a [ __ ] convention and
it's so cute I like it looks I wonder if
I have [ __ ] kids I'd want to take
them there what actually gets sold in
this convention though these conventions
provide a place for fans to meet
exchange ideas transact business and
engage in entertainment and recreational
center recreation centered on this
concept [ __ ] but it has nothing to do
with sex
I don't think they could promote them
maybe it's implied I don't think they
can pro that's why they don't have any
pictures on the maybe like after they
meet up with each other then they can
talk about it outside of it that just
looks like Comic Con to me like they're
just getting just that hanging out and
like yeah Anime Expo same with like
family to a certain group that doesn't
engage in sex maybe another I don't know
I'm not knowledge I don't I don't see
that in get horny well that's you don't
have to fetish that's why yeah I think I
mean if I had that fetish I [ __ ] see
them in their like costume and then
they're like wearing a lingerie or
something so it's sexualized it's not
sexualized but they don't need it to be
sexualized assigned like people who have
like PI affiliate you just you're like
oh damn you gon candy to me it's like a
sexual fetish where they get turned on
by having a Python in somebody's face
don't take Anna Marie Callender's yeah
there's that too and specifically it's
the pot that's so much the throwing of
the pie it's when pie gets in the hair
oh yeah I'm glad I just get horny off a
normal [ __ ] I don't know what that is
but there's no like sexual you don't to
be in lingerie to do it they just it's
just the pie but that furry convention
looks so fun like if I was a kid I'd
want to go there and hug everybody or
like it's like going to beam park and
then you see Fido or like you see like
well some people get turned on by making
I hope they shall they see up at these
conventions this looks really really
warm they should do that in the winter
time you know how they're like mixed
martial arts yeah there's the night
version of it
well like straight up you're in knight
in shining armor type of that is a sword
and a [ __ ] shield and you beat the
living [ __ ] out of each other
like og Stein can you [ __ ] can it cut
through can it cut through you got a
blunted lay there bunch so there's
whacking each other oh god it looks
pretty [ __ ] fun it must be [ __ ]
loud as [ __ ] that yeah and they're
like you could tell like they've been
doing it for a while because they're
like have technique and [ __ ] they're
wearing armor and then they have a
shield and a sword and a whole like
Knight armor and everything they move
fast the movement killer it's like slow
uh it looks pretty [ __ ] fast to me
maybe it's because of weapons coming at
you but the armor that they have is
really heavy if you want about not a few
hundred I think like a hundred pound
armors like that afraid I was reading up
on it we had an uber driver this was
like the most interesting remember that
whatever and he was a knight the most
interesting Luber driver he picked us up
in his car was like entirely covered in
stickers and then we go inside he's
wearing like this lay a Hawaii print
like t-shirt he's like well my goal here
is just to make you feel like you're on
a vacation with Vickers just the way he
was dressed
and he's like would you guys like some
water or whatever and then he was just
like talking about like how he's into my
little pony his friends he met the My
Little Pony gang through his furry
connections and we were like sitting
there like what the [ __ ] he's go why you
need them those taxi cab that says hey
don't talk to me nobody was really quite
enjoying them he was pretty nice it was
pretty interesting cuz he was just like
so much non-judgmental you know and he
was just right if he [ __ ] wolves she
but he was just so cool about it like he
thought collects baseball cards and
watches the NBA like it was that casual
we were like okay well we're in the
wrong for not knowing what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
yeah if you if you meet a person that
enjoys [ __ ] a guy in a camel outfit
he has no right to judge you that's true
that'd be so funny everybody's accepted
because I talk about like all the weird
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] and then you're like
um you have like a neon or something oh
yeah you're one of those people like
excuse me there still are those people
though but he was just so cool like you
just didn't know how to not engage in
conversation and I'm a [ __ ] I don't
like talking to people but I was just
like interesting tell me more I wish
sometimes like driving a fans well fans
are [ __ ] sick like an 18-man that's
cool no I'm talking about like a like a
Toyota Sienna like a hockey bag
it makes saying driving a Prius is cool
that's impossible but the difference
between that and advantage event is the
most comfortable thing to drive on this
earth a tee and the doors slide they
don't even open so he could be in a
tight circle this is one of the most
convenient things in the yard then
because in the hood they lower the van
no prints
those things smell a certain way to
those oh oh I'll talk about saw a Honda
Odyssey with like fat [ __ ] rams and
[ __ ] and it was all blacked out I was
like damages dope see it can look cool
yeah but for sure I did get me fun of
them yeah I still get me fun on that
horse dude
I mean Tesla - a minivan yeah probably a
clown doll you just gotta make it look
cool what might beat you up yeah
hey guys thanks for watching this
episode if you want to submit your own
articles check out the link in the
description box below and if you want to
see more videos check them out
right over here
[Music]